Peggy 18 hi i'm scott amos the executive
producer on Tomb Raider definitive
edition in this dev diary we'll look at
some of the technology and techniques we
use to bring Lara's world to life on the
next-gen consoles in our last video we
showed you Lara's improvements with her
new subsurface scattering the new
dynamic material blends on her skin and
more now let's take a look at what we
did to the environment around her we
went through every area in the game and
upgraded all the normal maps to make
everything feel like a real surface you
can reach out at touch
we took the textures to four times the
resolution so that they look great at
1080p and then layered all the new
normal and spec maps on top we hand
placed a ton of new vegetation foliage
of all types trees they react to the
wind as well as bushes and plants that
are physically simulated so they react
to Laura's movements we also have
reactive water you can see the surface
rippling respond to Laura's movements
it's a subtle detail that really helps
tie Laura to the world around her
new dynamically lifts particles mean
fire armors have a hotness and a glow to
them also individual raindrops are lit
by lightning and searchlights
our rewritten particle engine gives us
up to 15 times more particles in any
area we can use this to add dust
anything you can think of as particle
effects woodchips and sparks flying
around during combat fire embers during
an inferno we're even flocks of seagulls
we have thousands of seagulls launched
from a cliffside and fly into the sunset
all of this adds to the wow factor and
immersion of the world newly added
shadow casters means fires and
searchlights create realistic
silhouettes we also added full cloth
simulation
this thing's too realistic flapping of
Flags clothing and other debris all of
which are affected by the strength of
the wind
so that's a quick tour of some of the
things we've done to make Lara's world
next-gen from the new dynamic youlet
particle system to reactive water and
cloth to the enhanced lighting and
shadow casting this is truly the
definitive edition of Tomb Raider